Hi guys, and welcome to my 1GP to 1m
flipping guide uh for Old School
Runescape. I made one of these uh about
a week ago, which was going from 1GP to
max cash stack. Uh but I thought I would
possibly elaborate a little bit more on
the introductory section uh because this
is arguably the hardest point of
flipping. You don't have any experience.
You don't have any money. Uh so it takes
a while to get started. And I thought it
would help clarify a couple things uh
about this section.
So, what I'm going to be going over in
this guide is how to pick items that are
actually going to be profitable at this
amount of money and how to find their
margins uh without losing too much money
or taking uh big risk at all. And yeah,
so if you're new to flipping, definitely
stick around and uh let's get started.
So, for what you should know already, uh
just some basic things about the Grand
Exchange, um how to find a margin, and
just some information on the GE buying
limits. Uh if you don't know about any
of these things, I will link a beginner
flipping guide uh in the description. Uh
so you can go ahead watch his video and
then go have a look at that one later.
I'll try to keep it simple. Uh but if
you need a little more information about
the basics, there will be a guide in the
description. So for the most important
part of uh flipping any stage is the
item selection. Uh now what I'm going to
heavily recommend uh for those of you
who don't really have any money uh I
would recommend starting at maybe 50k
you could start picking items like this
and that is clue scroll items uh from
the easy, medium, and hard category. Uh
now this is the exact same thing I
mentioned in my last video. Uh we're
going to go more in depth into the items
and which ones you could actually try uh
because they are the only items you're
going to get good margins on uh for
cheap. Uh the reason is because they do
not trade a lot. What you're going to be
looking for are items between um 50 and
300 or something traded daily. uh
because that way you will be able to
check the margin of the item but still
be assured that you will be able to
actually flip at least a couple of them
or else you will be breaking even or
losing money even. Uh so that's why
we're going to choose items. We're not
going to choose the slowest of the items
like 10 or 20 traded a day cuz that'll
be pretty risky if you're going to
manually check the margin. Um but yeah,
so let's go ahead and look at some
examples. Okay, so uh we're going to be
starting with uh 50k today. And I'm
going to go through uh the complete
process of how I pick uh low-level
items. Uh now, of course, you could
start flipping from 1GP, but um more
often than not, it's going to be a lot
easier to just get to 50k, uh kill some
cows, pick up some bones, do what you
got to do. But once you have 50k, uh we
can get started. So, first of all, I
usually like to look at the wiki page.
So, this is uh the treasure trail wiki
page. It lists the easy, medium, hard,
elite, and master clue rewards. Uh, so
mostly you're going to want to stick to
the um easy, medium, hard rewards when
you have a very low amount of money uh
because they will inherently be cheaper.
But um some of the elite rewards are
pretty cheap as well. Uh one item I was
looking at was the vestment stalls. Um
so I think we're going to try one of
these. Now, what I do next is I want to
see how many of these are traded a day
cuz um the only way to be 100% sure of
the margin is to price check it. Um so,
I'm going to show you two different
ways. Of course, I am sponsored by GT
Tracker. So, I do and do personally
think that G Tracker is easy to use, but
I'm going to use OS Buddy Exchange just
because it is a little bit easier um to
hop on right away. You don't need an
account. But, um we're going to look up
the Gothics
Crosier.
And what we're looking for is the amount
traded per day because this graph uh
isn't going to be super up to date on
OSBuddy. But what is very useful still
is the amount traded per daily. Uh so we
can see roughly about 50 or 60. Um so
you could expect to buy and sell one of
these maybe one or two an hour. Doesn't
seem like a lot, but um when you leave
offers in all day definitely can pay
off. Um we're also going to look it up
on G Tracker here. Um, and it's going to
have pretty much the same information.
Looks like about 50 or um 60 traded a
day. And you can see the general prices
here. It does look like it has a pretty
good margin. But we're going to assume
we don't have access to that
information. And we're just going to go
manually check it cuz that's the only
way to be 100% sure. Uh, but now that
we've checked that uh it trades enough,
we can't we know at least that we're
going to get our money back uh if we
flip this item. Because if there's only
10 or 20 traded a day, you like you
might wait a day just to flip two of
them and that's pretty much break even
at that point. So Gothics Crosier, we're
just going to do a regular margin check.
So we bought it for 12K
and we sold it for 5.7K. So yes, we did
lose 7K there, but we can go ahead and
now reby the item. we can afford
seven of them. Um, you also do want to
make sure the item is cheap enough that
you can buy enough um afterwards. So,
seven of them for 40k and it looks good.
So, if we go back to G Tracker quickly,
I can see how many have been traded in
the last four or five hours. I think an
offer like this might take half a day to
complete. And it does seem like a lot a
long time, but uh if we look at our
return here, uh so 40k is what we're
spending on the items. And we're making
about a
6.5k profit on each one. So we're
looking to make uh double our money
pretty well. Uh which is extremely good.
If you were doing that at a higher cash
tack, you'd be laughing because that
would be a ton of money. But um the
margin here is really good. I think this
is promising and we'll come back uh when
we bought the items. Okay, so all the
Gthics Cros have bought. Um reasonably
quickly, couple hours definitely for
sure, but not too long. Now, this is
where sometimes I would recheck the
price of the item. Uh since I don't
actually have enough cash, I'm not even
going to bother. But when you've bought
uh 10, 20, 30 of an item, it's
definitely worth re-checking uh the
price you're going to be selling it for.
Uh because it can affect you negatively
if it's risen up or if it's uh crashed
down. But in this case, we're just going
to take the 12K and try to sell it for
that. Uh so we're going to pop it in
there for $1199.
And uh I know a lot of people are going
to mention undercutting. Uh my stance on
it is for items like this, it's kind of
fair game. Only one person can
legitimately be flipping this at a time.
Uh so it's I know this sounds a little
bit self-entitled, but it's kind of your
item until you're done with it. Um
whereas higher volume items, they can be
shared since there most people will hit
the buying limit and then someone else
can do it. It's better to not undercut.
Uh but again, for items like this, I
just my personal opinion. I feel like
it's not a huge deal if you undercut.
Anyway, with that out of the way, looks
like we're going to sell it for 84K, uh,
which is going to net us about
35k profit, which is pretty good. All
right, guys. We're back and we did sell
off all the Gothics Crosier for 12k. Uh,
now a lot of people ask how long flips
like this can take. This one took about
12 hours or half a day. Uh, but we did
net about 37k in total. Uh, so you can
see that flipping cheaper clue score
rewards can be very profitable uh, for
the amount of money I have at least. I
mean, technically we only have to do
that double our money like uh, six or
seven more times and we bit a mill
already. Uh, so it's really easy and
we'll go ahead and get a couple more
examples going for you. All right, so
we're going to go ahead and find one
more example for you guys. Um, so I've
been looking up some items and again
we're just back on the treasure trail
page. Now what I was looking at was the
crier hat. Um, this one here, uh, the
crier bell I've done before and the
crier code as well. Just a clue scroll
reward. It's from, uh, medium clues. Uh,
so we're going to go look at RS buddy
and go to crier at.
[Music]
Um, so these three tabs indicate um,
what type of graph you want to look at.
The month graph is going to give a data
point of each day when you look at it.
So that's what we're going to just going
to keep it on. I don't know if I
mentioned that earlier. Uh, so each
point is going to be one day. So it's
kind of nice to see uh how many are
traded per day. So you can kind of have
a standardized uh view of it. So it
looks like Cry Hats sell between 15 and
100 a day. So that's perfect. Still
within um the kind of rare item
category, but not the rarest of the
rare. Um so that might be good. And you
can also have a quick look uh and kind
of see what the price trends is. We'll
have a look at it on GT Tracker. And
again, the information should be pretty
well the same. Uh we can have a quick
look at uh the margins looking like 8 to
14K. Uh looks good. So we'll go ahead
and price check this item. So crier hat
going to instantly buy it for somewhere
around 15k
uh 14k and we're going to instantly sell
it for 9k. Uh so it's about a 5k profit.
Uh not bad. 4.5k. Uh, so we'll do that
item. Now, if you ever come to an item
that just does not have a good margin,
then it's not a big deal because you
didn't actually lose much money checking
it. If this only had a 1k margin, I
would just abandon it and not even do
it. Uh, so we're going to go ahead and
do well, I'll do five. Uh, well,
six. And um, yeah. So, we'll come back
when we flip the item. Okay, so we're
back and the crier hats did finally
sell. Now, this item did take a long
time and as you can see, we only bought
three of them. Uh, so we're only
profiting uh two times worth of the
item. So I wouldn't really end up doing
this again, I don't think. Uh, we only
profited
well
6k or something. Not a lot, but you get
the idea. Um, this pretty much can be
scaled up to any level. Although at a
certain point I wouldn't price check the
item just because the risk can get
really big uh for like high expensive
clue scroll item. Sometimes I price
check an item and you're losing a mill
and it's just not fun at that point. At
that point, I would start doing a
different method and just try to guess
or use third party tools. But for this,
you're not risking a lot. I easily just
price check the items. Again, make sure
that the amount traded per day is
looking good. And if so, go ahead and do
it. So, I do have a couple videos on my
channel that are um from 1GP to 1 mil,
two to be precise. I'll leave a link for
those in the description as well. Uh, so
yeah, let's go on with some example
items. All right, so now that we've gone
over a couple example flips, I thought I
would now go over a couple items, uh,
just break down where they are from and
why I think they'd be good to flip. Uh,
so to start off, uh, I have three items
here. Now, I picked these items
specifically because they are not clue
scroll items. Uh, but they are still
similar to why clue scroll items are
good. Uh, they don't trade a lot per
day, but they still are active and
people still need them. Uh so to start
off first is the elemental talisman.
This is a very cheap item. Uh usually
you can buy between 2 or 3k and
sometimes sells for 6 or 7k. This item
is obtainable in the um abyss and not a
lot of people use it but some people do.
So it makes uh for a pretty decent item
to flip when you don't have a lot of
money. Uh next up is a granite armor
piece. Um used quite a bit more h and
does cost more maybe 30 or 40k but this
item still can work uh very well. uh
rare because it's still not a very
widely used armor piece, but still has a
niche market. All right, next up is the
proite armor set. Uh kind of like the
granite armor, it's a bit of a niche
item, very useful, so people still want
it, but uh not used in everyday combat.
Uh so it leads to only being traded a
couple hundred a day, and you can
actually get really good margins on it.
Uh next up is the leafbladed sword, or
really any leafbladed item. Again, very
niche, only used for a certain amount of
slayer tasks. And the way you get this
item is from a drop. Uh so it leads to
there only being a couple hundred traded
a day and good margins. Uh next up is an
event item party hat. I wouldn't really
recommend this item that much uh because
it has a very low buying limit. Uh you
can only buy I think five of these every
4 hours. Uh so you're not going to make
much money on this, but still sometimes
can have a decent margin. Might be worth
trying. Next up is actually a mystic
boot. Uh mystic boot white. So it's just
a rare monster drop. So because of that
there aren't a lot traded it every day
but still people want it for kind of
fashion escape. So again has a use. You
probably get a five or 5 to 10k margin
on this item sometimes uh just because
people don't really uh buy this one cuz
I think it's more expensive than the
regular mystic boot. Anyway, and last up
is the clue scroll items. Now I kind of
just picked three at random because of
how the clue scroll works. Uh there's
kind of a similar amount of a lot of
items entering the game because you
don't have a choice in what item you
get. So a lot of clue scroll items,
almost all of them will be traded uh
just because
it's a random reward. So all these
rewards uh will even out and all the
items will be coming into the game at a
similar rate. Of course, some are just a
lot better than others and will
inherently trade more. Uh but what we
have here is the blacksmith helm. It's
about a 100k item. Used to be really
expensive. have came out with the clue
scroll expansion. Then we have the
brascin shield, a much cheaper item. And
of course, the s herdome and kite
shield. Any god wars uh rune items can
trade quite a bit, but they're still
pretty good to flip. Uh same with their
trimmed counterpart. Those work really
well. Um so yeah, hope you guys enjoyed
the uh video about flipping from 1 GP to
1 mil. Hopefully you got some more ideas
on what items you can flip. And if you
did enjoy the video, don't forget to
subscribe to my channel uh for more
flipping videos. All right, have a good
day, guys, and I'll see you in the next
video.
[Music]